all right so today's topic uh doji cat
if you aren't aware doji cat's uh an
artist
uh she does r b i don't know what she
does
i don't think i listen to records it's
not r b
she does weird music period okay she's a
weird person except that
and um recently she was on uh i think
it's tiny chat
which is similar to omegle except you
don't have the consent to just leave
whenever you want
she goes on and um
she starts doing it was super weird i
can't even explain it
let's go to the end
yes
[Music]
her shirt reminds
so um doja from the research i did
she's uh she's pretty young and a lot of
her
discussions a lot of her stuff is
basically her talking about her
her poom poom and what she likes to do
and how she likes to get and all this
stuff so when i saw this the first time
i saw it
to me i instantly recognized it as race
play
if you're not familiar with race play
it's a form of domination it's like
it's like a kink that some people have
where they love to use racial slurs
uh on have racial service used on
themselves
and it turns them on i actually remember
watching a prawn
video a long time ago and
as the thing was going i was enjoying i
was like yeah i'm about to about to bust
on
bust these guts um the white girl just
starts dropping n bombs and the guy gets
just like yeah
yeah yeah and i was like wait what's
happening and i remember being so
disgusted because i maintained my
erection
right so i was like am i problematic too
you know the funny thing is what
you know when people talk about uh when
they talk about
them and stuff like that right and
there's part of it that's you know uh
domination waiting with people yeah
i would never yeah have someone with me
especially not a white girl especially
not a white but you don't want to play
the little
slave master fantasy no if if i play the
fantasy i'm the slave master
yeah repetitious
that's that's you know what i mean you
want some white stuff on your white face
[Laughter]
if i if i no if i yeah yeah it's like
isn't it funny that white people were so
good at whip
but they didn't know how to do the whip
dance
get the [ __ ] out of here take all your
[ __ ]
i know it's your room take all your [ __ ]
and get the [ __ ] get
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Applause]
now watch me win a picture it's not like
my ancestors used to do it
yeah maymay you're not doing that you're
not with me no
no no no no all right no that's not
happening
just the irony that dawned on me in a
second there that's funny but yeah so
go on so it's a former race player and i
have friends who who work in that
industry and then
they get requests like that from black
men all the time where they
want to be talked down to like that and
it turns them on and this struck me as
the same thing because if you listen to
what she says
she says s my d and call me
n-word yeah right if i'm paraphrasing
properly and it struck me
as that kind of weird stuff she looked
like a woman in heat it was really weird
to watch
i feel like there's certain things that
just have to be kept in the private life
yeah you know what i mean to me it's
like dark humor
okay oftentimes that's just best done in
a comedy club in front of a live
audience who knows what the context of
the jokes are
when you're doing dark humor online with
no context and people hear that stuff
about you wanting to drown me
it's hard for a lot of people if you
want to write it down and put it in a
newspaper
then there's no context right exactly so
this is what that struck me as
i'm not a fan of hers i don't like what
she does i can't stand her music i can't
stand her persona
that being said when i watch this stuff
that's what it looks like it looks like
a junkie and i know that she loves that
kind of submissive being talked down to
the fuckiest thing about me you don't
want to ask me
i'm cancelled that's all i'm saying i'm
my ass it's cancer
oh no you knew this [ __ ] was coming
he knew this [ __ ] was coming here we go
good job the freakiest i like to be
stepped on
step down i like to be stepped on is it
a foot thing
i don't it's not a foot thing is it a
shoe thing it's like a power thing
right she she that that's that
submission that was what that was so i'm
not i'm not i'm not surprised about that
there's
but the thing that happened is that
there's a lot of things that are adding
on to that right there's
this thing there's that interview there
is
when she talks about well she's happy
that she's a white girl with
you know that that she's a light skinned
not a dark skin that has a booty
it's the agglomeration of all of that
yeah
you know it's it's all that puts it it's
not just one thing
so it's just little things you know
whenever you meet someone and you talk
to them
and they always they offer you go on a
blind date you meet someone i'm gonna
say blind
hold up you said agglomeration my [ __ ]
and you invented that word and i know
what you was trying to say but that's
just funny
it's not a word no it should be though
it should be yeah
yeah that's agglomeration i think i
think
i think everybody should profit of that
word
you know private is now an urban
dictionary i know [ __ ]
i know what the [ __ ] i do okay this is
my [ __ ] game
i'm out of it but yeah agglomeration so
you're saying it's basically the
accumulation of all these different
yes it's all of that is this thing that
thing all of that
put together there's no doubt that she
probably has a lot of issues with her
identity with her race
and i understand that and most mixed
people have that problem does it give
him a pass
not necessarily no right some of the
stuff that she said in the past yo
listen hold her accountable if you guys
want i ain't mad at that
that being said when it comes to this
specific clip i just wanted to give you
guys that context and make you
understand
what it was that you're looking at yo
she has a song about
didn't do nothing that's that's what
that was the song is didn't do nothing
basically what it is it's just a
a slur that premises used
to uh make fun of whenever you know
black
black person gets shot all the fan is
like the family's like
well he didn't do nothing why did you
that's the way that they used
they did that's a word that they used to
make fun of them people uh and didn't do
nothing
you know i mean she made a whole song
about it
she has some some some issues with the
whole uh
who she is as a is she black is she is
she white
what she said she makes she's a poc
right a person of color
i don't really like that term know who
you are right people who want trying to
be
too safe people try to be too safe and
be like you know what i'm a person of
color not to offend nobody because we
can't say this we can't say that
whatever
so there's a bunch of things like that
i'm uncertain about this person i saw
that i was like well
it's weird but she's been weird she has
it to me she hasn't done
anything that surprises me and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
would she do this if i was they if i was
jay-z i'd be like oh that's a bit off
but that to me is like yeah it goes with
that behavior
the little did i know about that persona
whatever is that it's super weird
super weird remember when marilyn manson
came out
no oh yeah you're that young wow
god i'm old meredith manson came out
and there's a bunch of things that were
they were talking about what he was
doing in the shows and
video clips and stuff like that a lot of
it was not true
some of it was true but i was not
surprised that's the whole persona of
the thing
that's the whole that's what it was so
i'm not
i'm not i'm not i'm in no way shape or
form
surprised about what happened with that
it's a whole instagram live
where she talks about her her supreme
interest in older white men
now look some people love to believe
that a lot of these racial preferences
that people have are just born in a
vacuum
no no they're not okay a lot of this
stuff is born from
your own prejudices your own biases that
are built over time
your lived experiences 100 there's a
reason why in some places they have
yellow fever and other places they don't
the way we perceive media
our own experiences affects our
interests right and i'm going to cover
this in a separate video but
i i can't stand people like i like what
i like no why do you like what you like
some of it is informed it's not you're
just born this way because if it was we
would have consistency over time but the
reality is
beauty standards have changed we like
fat asses now we didn't like them 25
years ago
right that's media affecting our
perception of what we lack in that same
token
there's something affecting her
perception where she has this kind of
idea
now am i going to shame her for her key
no i'm not
i think this would be something that she
should keep behind closed doors keep it
in your bedroom
obviously don't be a [ __ ] goofball
right don't be a goober
who posts it on on time chat what are
you doing that's
she she's stupid but she's young and
she's got a lot of money
i'm not expecting a young rich dumb
person to make smart decisions
thank god i got this money now and not
when i was 19. hell yeah brother hell
yeah
you already know it would have i'd be
hyper problematic yo i'd be i'd be a
yeah
that'd be it'd be a problem yeah it
would be a problem yeah so
listen as much as i want to to hate on
doja because i dislike her
this is like my take on it but i didn't
even i ain't
not surprised yeah but even beyond being
not surprised
is it good or bad behavior that's what
we're talking about you being surprised
is one thing
that's one thing right like is this good
or bad and the reality is
this lives in a gray area and in this
time when we're doing all this
acceptance of all this weird stuff
this is one of those things we just
happen to have a glimpse into it and
it's really weird but there's no doubt
that she has other problems when it
comes to her identity
and i will give you guys that but i
wanted to just fill you guys in on that
kind of kink
world like i said before when the
cameras was off it's not because you
have a kink in the bedroom that it
defines
your morals right it's not because you
like to be dominated in the bedroom
because in the bedroom you're gonna have
some
control over that yeah so it's not the
real thing
it's not the real thing if a woman wants
you to choke her
it doesn't make her it's it makes you
think yeah
you know but it doesn't it doesn't mean
my suspicion of how she's going to
handle this is she's going to explain
that this is something that she likes
doing but that she recognizes was wrong
and she apologized but she's going to
explain it away as if it was
you know a kink a kink and then like in
a couple of years in like 10 20 years
yeah she's gonna be part of a
documentary surviving dodger cat
she's gonna do something i'm just
kidding but i'm just saying but
that's a great parallel to bring because
i like people like she's canceled bruh
if y'all didn't cancel art kelly for 25
years you're not gonna cancel her okay
yo girls at concerts yeah pee on me
yeah yeah listen come on people are
gonna keep buying those records and keep
listening
so that's the reality of the world we
live in i'm not saying i like it i'm
just telling y'all what it is
so anyways we want to hear your thoughts
let us know
what you think in the comments below uh
yeah that's it
i don't see nothing wrong
[Music]